[Applause]
turn a new page in fear with Hillhouse
comics a terrifying new line of horror
comics generated by johanna the
mastermind behind no spiritu and lock
and key get ready to shock your senses
with some of the biggest names in horror
storytelling unleashing their most
disturbing nightmares basket full of
heads June has a supernatural acts that
could decapitate a man in one stroke but
leave his head is still impossibly alive
ranting and mad for revenge how many
heads will she have to collect to save
her boyfriend the dollhouse family
playtime never ends
young Alice loves her antique dollhouse
but doesn't know that it's using her as
its plaything
woods welcome to shudder to think
Pennsylvania where skinless men and
antlered women walked the woods and
reality is falling in on itself
Daphne burn a voice called from the
other side
she answered what's a young girl
supposed to do when a charming demon
invades her mind plunge a research
ship's crew returns after 40 years lost
at sea they haven't aged a day but what
happened to their eyes
it allows comics it's okay if you need
to scream
you